today I'd like to discuss what I think
is a really good natural protocol for
both myocarditis as well as autoimmune
myocarditis there is a lot of recent
videos on internet that you can find out
on potential causes of this disorder
whether it's viruses from medication
from a vaccine from some toxin so I'm
not going to get into that what I do
want to talk about is what to do
naturally what are some alternative
things that you can try and why you
should try certain things now the
problem with myocarditis in the first
place is we have this inflammatory
condition in the heart muscle which can
then lead to fibrosis which can then
give you a whole list of additional
problems from dizziness to shortness of
breath chest pain the inability to
exercise chronic fatigue syndrome
irregular heartbeats and the list goes
on and on and on so when researching
this topic I found a good amount of
research on several remedies that I want
to discuss in order of what I think is
important and the first remedy is called
Japanese not wheat okay this is an
invasive weed that spreads all over the
place
yet it has some really interesting
properties number one it has Resveratrol
which we all know is an anti-aging
phytonutrient but it also has something
else called imodin okay what is that
that is a natural chemical it decreases
inflammation and also it's antiviral and
so that would be the first remedy I
would recommend and as far as dosage
goes whatever is recommended on the
label I would just take that just one
time per day now the next most important
thing to take is a type of vitamin E
that is not tocopherol called tocotrino
okay and it's not just tocotrino it's
tocotrinoles it's there's several
different types so you want to get a
blend there's the alpha beta Delta gamma
without the tocopherols now the question
is why tucatrinos has some very
interesting properties
it can help inhibit fibrosis so if you
have inflammation in your heart muscle
um the worst thing you can get is scar
tissue so this can potentially help
prevent that formation plus it has a
powerful anti-inflammatory action so
combining decreasing inflammation as
well as stopping the conversion from
inflammation to fibrosis is a really
good thing and tocatrinos also has been
studied on the inside of the artery as
well but in this situation we want it to
act on the heart and muscle The
myocardium the problem with mixing
tocotrinos with decoforal is they both
will have a tendency to compete with
each other so we don't want that we want
the tocatrinos only without the
decoferols because tocatrinos are
roughly about 50 times stronger and when
we're dealing with myocarditis we want
to do whatever we can to put out the
fire and whatever it says on the back of
the label I would recommend
times three okay you just take it three
times a day morning afternoon and night
and if you could take it with a little
food or a little bit of oil okay like
olive oil or coconut oil it will absorb
much better and number three vitamin D3
why because vitamin D3 is the most
potent vitamin for inflammation it's not
really even a vitamin it's like a
natural hormone that has very strong
anti-inflammatory properties and we're
trying to put out this inflammation so
vitamin D3 is essential and it's also
really good for any type of autoimmune
disorder as well I would recommend
taking in 10 000 IU units twice a day so
it would be a total of a twenty thousand
IUS per day and you just split it up
take ten thousand I use in the morning
and ten thousand I use in the evening
and so vitamin D3 kind of acts like
cortisol but without the side effects
because one of the medical treatments
for this is steroids because they're
trying to get rid of inflammation so by
taking the vitamin D3 you're kind of
having this steroid effect without the
side effects all right the next remedy
is called olive leaf extract you know
about the olive oil you know about
olives but this is something in the leaf
and there's a compound called oleanolic
acid but there's some great research on
mice showing a significant benefit on
autoimmune myocarditis olive leaf
extract is both anti-inflammatory as
well as anti-viral I recommend it to
people that have viruses in general but
for this Condition it's a really good
good natural remedy with very minimal
side effects all right and the last
remedy I'm going to recommend and it's
called
cardiotrophin PMG and I would recommend
taking one before bed now why would I
recommend cardiotropin PMG
because it has extracts of actual animal
heart tissue you're going to take that
into your stomach the antibodies that
you have they're attacking your own
heart will go after this decoy in your
stomach and hopefully reduce the
antibodies that are attacking your heart
so it's kind of a strategy of having
this decoy and rerouting these
antibodies to reduce the inflammation or
the attack on your own tissues now is
there any scientific studies that show
that this will work absolutely not it's
just my theory that it may help you you
might want to try it you really have
nothing to lose and it could potentially
help you now I would also recommend not
exercising of any significant amount
because there's damage to the heart and
there's inflammation in the heart and
you don't want to stir that up maybe
some very light walking but nothing
of any high intensity because we have a
situation where the heart can never rest
it always has to work and it's inflamed
so we want to reduce inflammation and
this is why you would also want to do at
the same time the healthy version of the
ketogenic diet where you're eating just
really healthy foods that are naturally
anti-inflammatory as well as doing just
regular intermittent fasting so you're
not snacking you're not doing prolonged
fasting or you're doing just regular
intermittent fasting where you're
fasting for a period of time that alone
is going to help reduce inflammation so
there you have it what I think is a
really good protocol for either
myocarditis or autoimmune myocarditis
now since we did touch on tocotranos and
the importance of Toco channels for the
heart I think this next video would be
the best video for you to watch check it
out I put it up right here